[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
it's punch a Nazi Friday
who's against bunch of Nazis I don't
know that there's many people out there
better against it
[Music]
oh but the outrage
Nancy Pelosi wanting to punch out the
former president Donald Trump for
wanting to overturn our elections and
our government and our way of life
yesterday was day nine of the January 6
elect hearings
and the Cheeto dust mobster was supined
subpainted subpoenaed subpoenaed
to appear before the January 6 select
committee he won't do it because he's a
[__]
I'll be listening you are a [__]
[__] you're not gonna go talk to the
January 6th so like I mean you
definitely you definitely are not going
to take questions from Liz Cheney you
little [__] no [__] way no way does
Donald Trump go and get questioned by
Liz Cheney he's terrified of her
absolutely [__] terrified and
terrified of the select committee in
general
yesterday was proof of that he didn't he
didn't post on fraud social
until they subpoenaed him and then he
lost his mind he was posting Q Anon
videos
Q Anon conspiracy videos he was posting
where clipped up Rachel Maddow to make
it sound like Rachel Maddow was on his
side
okay okay Grandpa go with that one go
with that lie
yesterday there was a lot of
groundbreaking
news and we knew most of this again this
is not stuff that we didn't already know
we just didn't have the you know the
proof
I like the proof of Steve scalise being
a pile of [__] garbage
we knew that was the truth we just
didn't have the evidence and until
yesterday
Steve scalise been saying oh Nancy
Pelosi is the one that's responsible for
the Insurrection and the violence at the
Capitol she did nothing she did nothing
she stood back and watched it happen as
he was standing standing next to her
while she was trying to get any and
every law enforcement officer or
national Guardsmen
or or security at the Capitol to clear
out the [__] Scourge the shark army
as it was
and is
so that way they could get back to
business of government
and they didn't have the risk of
people's lives and safety
we've never seen that footage before
really we didn't until yesterday even
know that it existed
the Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer even John
thune and Mitch McConnell
were working to try to get the shark
army
out of our government business
even Republicans
like Steve scalise standing there
listening to Nancy Pelosi saying anyone
and everyone you can bring help us
please we need to make sure people are
safe
and we need to get back to government
she knew it was a vital key to make sure
people's safety she didn't give a [__]
about the ransacking and the [__]
smearing and people stealing stuff and
breaking things that was secondary to
people's safety
and our democracy
even on the phone with the vice
president now we we we have witnessed
pictures and video
from the parking garage
where Mike Pence is on the cell phone
with a notepad and a pen
and we assumed at that moment that the
vice president was trying to hold the
government together
was so as Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of
the House
and Chuck Schumer the majority leader in
the Senate they were trying to hold the
government together
because they were trying to steal it
from us
all with the strategic planning of this
spaghetti excuse me ketchup at the wall
strategy of we'll try anything and
everything
to make sure that Donald Trump is Crown
King even
the idea that after the Secret Service
took him back to the White House and
said no grandpa you're not going to the
Capitol today it's not a place where
you're going you're going to sit here at
the White House this is your branch of
government
that's how branches
work
you're gonna sit here and eat your
cheeseburger and watch it on TV
even after that
We Now find out he was gonna still try
to go to the Capitol
and now there's the great tape of
History
and it is set in history forever and
ever and all time
that the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi
was so infuriated by even the idea
that this buffoon would try to come to
the Capitol to Crown himself King
as general of the shark army
and steal away our democracy
because he's a little [__] he's a punk
ass [__] so much so that she's like
I'll punch him out I'll [__] punch
him out
and I'll go to jail and I don't give a
[__] I'll be happy about it [__] them
anyone upset at the clip of Nancy Pelosi
talking about how she's willing to go to
jail if he comes up to the Capitol to
try to steal our government she's
willing to punch that Nazi you're you
are a Nazi
if you got a problem with that if you
got a problem with that little clip
of her saying no [__] you are
not stealing away our way of life you're
not stealing away this American
experiment
of democracy nope not gonna happen [__]
I'll lay you out on the floor
I'll go to jail over it
if you have a problem with that clip
you're a piece of [__]
because it wasn't just Nancy Pelosi that
was really pissed off that day
now we know now we know Kevin McCarthy
is a [__] coward course how much
proof do you really need
but now we have three three Witnesses
three Witnesses
of Kevin McCarthy's phone call to Donald
Trump
that Donald Trump said it's antifa
and Kevin McCarthy's like no it's it's
your supporters you told them to come
here
and to steal our government and they're
doing they're trying to do that
and Donald Trump says to Kevin McCarthy
well maybe Kevin
you just don't love me as much as they
love me
so now we know that Kevin McCarthy's a
[__] coward and Kevin McCarthy it's
time for you to resign
now right now it's time for you to
resign as the minority leader of the
house we do not need any leadership in
either party minority or majority that
is such a [__] coward that can't even
come out and tell the truth when the
capital was Under Siege when your staff
was running for their lives and you
stole that [__] that
it's time for Kevin McCarthy to resign
Steve scalise it is time for you to
resign today today I'm calling for it
everyone else should call for it
and really honestly we should we should
get the 14th Amendment out dust that
[__] off and start and start
declaring these [__]
insurrectionist I don't care if they
were insurrectionists during January 6
are now after
like right now in the moment Kevin
McCarthy and Steve scalise are
insurrectionist
maybe not on January 6 but they are
today
to try to repaint and reshape what
happened that day when they know they
were standing there [__] standing
there now we have the evidence
we don't need a guess
we don't need to take we don't need to
take second hand third hand fourth hand
accounts we got John tape you dumb
[__]
foreign
you cowardice pieces of [__] we don't
need you anywhere near our government
anywhere near our democracy we
definitely do not need you in leadership
for sure
it's now time for you [__] to resign
now you can do a great favor
in this way audience
you can let this piss you off as much as
rovember and them overturning the rights
of women
folks they're stealing away your bodily
autonomy they tried to steal your vote
and they're not gonna stop
Steve scalise stood next to Nancy Pelosi
in an undisclosed safe location trying
to get National Guardsmen and other
Security Forces to the Capitol to secure
the building to get the shark army out
so that they could do government
stood there listened he's a witness
on [__] film we see it
and the insurrectionist is trying to
steal away our vote again
by lying to the entire [__] Nation
he's supposed to be a leader
forget about [__] Donald Trump forget
about that [__]
history's already told that story of
that cowardice vile treasonous piece of
[__]
he's already cemented his little story
in history [__] him
that [__] is gonna go to jail
doubt me
mother he's [__]
yesterday the biggest 9-0 decision was
not the subpoena
the 9-0 decision was all his Supreme
Court Justices that he that they thought
were going to protect him told him nope
nope not gonna happen
dunked him in the trash
now it means a lot of different legal
things but the one thing it does mean
the one thing that does mean
is they hear you and I mean the Supreme
Court they hear you they hear you folks
they know how bad they piss this country
off
they know Clarence Thomas knows he could
have made this decision on his own
but he didn't he gave it to the entire
court and the entire court dunked it in
the [__] trash
almost at the same exact time when Liz
Cheney burned down Donald Trump's house
so Donald Trump has already submitted
his treasonous story into history it's
already cemented now we haven't written
the entire synopsis yet but it's there
he's already done it
Steve scalise
he's still committing insurrection
Kevin McCarthy is still doing
insurrection
how could you see it any other way
they're supposed to be leaders
they're supposed to swear an oath
it's time to dust off the 14th Amendment
I think yeah I think I think that's
where we need to go with this
[__] forget about indictments forget
about criminal charges everyone's
yelling and screaming about that nope
dust off the 14th Amendment
it's time to make sure these
[__] cannot hold leadership
positions they are obviously are
insurrectionists and they do not have
the constitutional right to hold
leadership positions in our government
it is a thing it's in the 14th Amendment
go look it up you treasonous pieces of
[__]
you megalodites in the chat go look it
up go look up the 14th Amendment you
search Google it DuckDuckGo Constitution
14th Amendment insurrectionist scope
looked that up
it's in there
now I know that's why you don't like the
14th because it doesn't allow you to be
a treasonous piece of [__] and destroy
our democracy I get it but that's what's
written
so we should use it
there's a perfect modern example Coy
Griffin he's an insurrectionist
they stripped him of his public office
of his leadership position
it's time we do the same for the rest of
these [__]
that are that are committing
Insurrection as we speak
Steve scalise and Kevin McCarthy are
actively trying to insurrect your vote
your election your government
so
what shall it be are you going to sit
out this election are you going to
finally get engaged and I know you're
engaged
but get others engaged it's time
it's time that people pay attention to
what's going on let me tell you
something
if any Republican or Trump supporter out
there any of these [__] in the chat
tell you no one watched yesterday no
watch this
you are full of [__]
we did coverage yesterday on the Midas
touch Network it was our most viewed
hearing
highest views the most people live and
otherwise
we were looking at other networks other
YouTube channels
all the highest
every one of them
America's paying attention
and if you're a trumpet if you're a
megalodite out there if you're a cultist
if you're a member of the Trump cult if
you're an America First Nazi
we're watching you
we see you
and we watched the hearing yesterday
and America is watching
I don't know exactly what the numbers
are
yet and we'll probably find out today or
sometime tomorrow what the actual
numbers
of this were and collectively I don't
just mean like ratings on networks I'm
talking about digital and otherwise
when we find out the numbers I'm sure
this is going to be Super Bowl numbers
Americans wanted to see what these
[__] pieces of [__] trying to do to
our country
that's bad that's bad for them
the insurrectionist like Steve scalise
and Kevin McCarthy all the [__] that
went to the Capitol broke in beat cops
with flagpoles weapons disguised as
flagpoles got their asses shot because
they were breaking into secure areas got
themselves killed
and even the folks that that incited it
planned it organized it
and then covered it up
Tony arnato is in a hell of a lot of
trouble here oh [__]
Tony arnato is in a lot of trouble a lot
let me tell you something the Department
of Justice there's one charge that they
take very very seriously
like there's murder right when you kill
people there's that charge and then
right below that is obstruction
they do not like obstruction right wrong
or indifferent well however you want to
look at it
they don't like it
prosecutors don't like it investigators
don't like it
judges don't like it juries tend to not
see it as a great thing to obstruct an
investigation
it really speaks to your criminality if
you're trying to obstruct it really does
and Tony arnato and Trump himself but
Tony arnato it seems as if he could be
in a lot of trouble
for obstruction and there's a lot of
other people that are going to be in
trouble for obstruction
a lot
obstructing an official proceeding and
just obstruction of justice
I'm sure we're going to mention the name
stodger Rhone today
as I say it was mentioned yesterday
during the hearing I got a special video
I retweeted this video MJ sent it to me
everyone give MJ the moderator in the
chat give her some love all the
moderators Margie
and Robin as well but MJ sent me a video
this morning
of Roger Stone
just being typical Roger Stone and it is
delicious oh it is delicious
I can't wait to show you this video
but it's Friday and you know what Friday
is here at the Tony Michaels podcast
it's bonehead of the week where you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week
and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez
breaks it down he's gonna be
tuning in with us today from the phone
booth that he was at yesterday during
the during the hearing it literally I
think it literally is a phone booth
it's in some secret Soros bunker
somewhere deep State kind of phone booth
kind of thing
secret internet stuff
so he's going to be joining us today for
bone hand of the week I think you'll
also join us for the [__] list I believe
I'm not sure
I'm not sure um
what what's the time limit on the um the
internet service there at the Deep State
phone booth but he'll be joining us uh
uh for the shitless Roundup and maybe
but bonehead of the week for sure a show
but show
yesterday was a great day for America
when we had the broadcast Lee McGowan
politics girl followed up the broadcast
with some of her commentary and she was
very saddened by the uh the footage that
we saw
that the damage that they tried to do to
our democracy and did inflict on our
democracy she was very upset
uh you guys know Lee McGowan from the
politics girl podcast but also her
videos her Tic Tacs her breakfast rants
and she has
um great commentary
and she was very saddened Yesterday by
the footage that we that we witnessed
that the that the January 6 elect
hearing or the committee at the hearing
laid before the American people make
sure to to show us exactly what happened
that day and the evidence that they have
collected
and she was very sad
and I it was it was very it was it was
very shocking to see
the footage
that we that we witnessed yesterday not
just the the seven minute video of the
leaders of the house and the Senate
trying to protect the capital from the
shark army but also
also the footage of the lead up and the
planning that was involved in this
and the forethought
they knew he was going to lose they knew
it
this idea that there's no way Trump lost
to Joe Madden they knew he was going to
lose they knew he lost
but they had planned to steal it the
entire time
the entire time they planned on stealing
there was never a moment
from the time that Trump decided to
rerun that he wasn't going to try to
remain present no matter what
any means necessary
rather he had to win an election or he
had to steal it cheat and steal our
democracy
and that is the damage that Lee McGowan
talked about yesterday
you should go and watch
after the hearing coverage maybe I'll
cut that part out
and for you guys to put it on our
YouTube channel just that part with
politics girl Lee McGowan
but I want to say something
as sad as it is as much as we have to
come to grips with the reality of what
these treasonous pieces of garbage did
to our democracy and tried to do to our
election in 2020.
it is up to us to act
it is up to us we have to act it is
crucially important it is not just
enough to know
you have to set it in motion you have to
engage now with the information that you
have
which is that the Republican Party
is a treasonous party
up and down all the way across the
full-scale board
if there is an R behind their name at
this point in time in history they are
trying to undermine our democracy and
your way of life your rights and your
freedoms
rather they're capitulating
rather they're it's it's not conscience
it doesn't matter
it's now time for us to engage with this
information that the January 6 elect
committee has given us
now they subpoenaed Donald Trump and
again he's a punk ass [__] he is not
gonna go and testify in front of the
January 6 elect committee
he'll take a criminal charge like Steve
Bannon and Peter Navarro and the rest of
them before he goes and has to sit
before Liz Cheney and answer her
questions he's too much of a goddamn
[__] he won't do it he's weak he's a
coward and she would absolutely punch
that Nazi figuratively speaking with her
question not literally like Nancy Pelosi
want to do
it's in the clip what am I supposed to
do I don't condone violence I'm just
reporting
I'm just reporting that Nancy blosey was
willing to go to jail
if Grandpa came up to the Capitol to try
to steal our democracy I don't blame her
I don't blame her hell on any given day
Friday punch a Friday Nazi or not I
don't care Sunday Monday Tuesday it
doesn't matter to me
now I'm not against I'm not against
good-hearted democropro democracy people
laying a sucker on a Nazi I'm not
we have to be intolerant of intolerance
that is what we have to do
and we have to meet them in this moment
because you heard it from Roger Stone
forget the voting let's start the
violence we don't need to vote let's
start the violence that's what Roger
Stone said that's the clip they played
yesterday
they were so hell-bent on stealing the
Democracy they didn't even help hell
with actually casting ballots
this is a guy who's in the ear of the
president United States at the time
who knows he's going to lose who knows
he's going to have to steal this away
who knows he's gonna have to sell the
big line to his [__] supporters
who knows he's going to try to have to
get them to come commit an Insurrection
who knows he's going to have to try to
commit a coup
and this guy in his ear stodgerone Roger
Stone
is saying [__] the vote don't even vote
don't even vote don't even let him vote
let's just get to the violence
that's what they wanted that's what they
knew they had to have because they know
we stand in front of them
that's why they [__] hate democracy
that's why they [__] hate it they
[__] hate it
and yes Lee is right what they did to
our democracy is disgusting it's gross
and it saddens me and it should sadden
all of us
doesn't matter where you stand on a
political ideology scale
it should sadden you what they did to
our democracy and tried to do to our
vote
but we must not relent
we must lean in
we must engage now with our democracy
it is the one thing they are terrified
of most and it is the best weapon we got
to crush fascism
is use the power of the ballot while you
still have it
so now is the time not yesterday not the
week before not next week right now time
is running out we're at October 14th
we're just under four weeks away
if you can still get people registered
to vote in your state do it if you can
request a mail-in ballot do it if you
can early vote do it now encourage
people get if you can early vote in your
state
are mail-in ballot in your state get
that done now and find three people who
will also do it and get them to find
three people who will also do it we have
to
pile these fascists under mountains of
ballots and there is way more of us than
there are of them
I'm confident very confident there is
way more of us that is the biggest fraud
that Trump has wrought on this country
is that half the country supports him
that is a load of [__] [__]
nope not not a thing
just go start asking people and private
how they feel you'll find out really
quick
you'll find out really quick everybody
thank you for joining us this week it's
been such a big week for news and such a
big week for us here at the Tony
Michaels podcast the audience is growing
and we really love having you here all
the new folks here whether you're on
Facebook YouTube twitch or Twitter we
welcome welcome welcome you
you can we run on your support
that's how we operate here you can go to
tonymichaels.live you can watch the show
there Tony Michaels dot live
and you can also give us a tip there we
run on your support again don't forget
that you can give a one-time tip or set
it up monthly a lot of you have done
that we appreciate all that you do but
the one thing that you guys love holy
moly is this thing right here this
t-shirt this design the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
this is our motto this is the entire aim
of the show
the whole [__] point of liberalism if
you want to know the truth
we also have it in hoodies there's
coffee mugs available there's now a zip
up Hoodie if you'd like the the Liberty
design and the Sip up Hoodie these
things are flying off the shelves I
really appreciate all the support that
you guys give you are the best audience
in the entire world and I do say world
because we got we got audience members
all around the world rather you're an
American that's overseas or you're just
one of our great allies
around the world for democracy you are
here and we see you too and we we hear
you too I see the comments
and so we welcome all the audience
members you are the best audience in the
world thanks for tuning in every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific we got
bonehead coming up but I got some videos
I want to show you in the meantime for
the shitless Roundup so don't go
anywhere sit tight sit tight don't go
anywhere we're gonna do a little bit of
[__] let's round up we're gonna surf the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends and
then what we're gonna do is gonna do
bone and oh the week
sit tight don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
tweets
and we'll go to the shitless Roundup as
we do every single Friday here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
every single Friday holy moly the
audience is getting bigger and bigger we
have more and more subscribers here on
YouTube don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button you don't want to miss
a thing here at the Tony Michaels
podcast also if you want to vote for
bonehead of the week if you miss it this
week don't worry if you subscribe to
YouTube you can find it there you can
also find it on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod follow us over there on Twitter also
follow me at the Tony Michaels and Buy
Low the co-host Gabe Sanchez at I am
Gabe Sanchez download every single
episode Monday through Friday on your
favorite directory Apple Spotify Google
do not forget to leave a review while
you're subscribing on your favorite
directory you don't want to forget that
if you're on Facebook right now whether
you're on the Midas touch or my page
make sure to follow at the Tony Michaels
follow us on Facebook if you're on
Facebook some people have Facebook some
people don't
some people left it a long time ago some
people stuck in with it
there's a big Facebook audience over
there that watches this every single day
so if you're on Facebook again follow my
page at the Tony Michaels I throw a lot
of memes up the people who follow me on
Facebook know I've got a lot of me I
find memes sometimes I make them I find
them and I I post them on Instagram and
Facebook you can follow me on Instagram
too also you can watch every single
weekday live on Twitch
so if you like twitch or if you're
looking for a different way to watch the
show maybe twitch is for you
there's a lot of folks over on Twitch
that like the chat over there just a
different experience it's a little it's
more of a live streaming platform it's
what it was designed for
so a lot of people won't get over there
on Twitch so check it out it's a free
app download I don't get anything for
you to download it
just follow us over there on Twitch you
can find all the Links at
thetonymichaels.com again the Tony
michaels.com and don't forget to visit
store.dtonymichaels.com you can also
find the link to the store on
d20michaels.com
you can get the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
this is the most popular design
that we have had in the store so far
coffee mugs sweaters or well hoodies and
then zip up sweaters with a hood
t-shirts
I don't know I think I might put it on a
metal sign too they got metal signs in
the store I might do that
maybe a banner I don't know maybe would
you hang it on the wall
I don't know I don't know
I I ordered I ordered my own shirt it's
it's coming it's coming so you'll see me
where the the Liberty design here even
though I don't you don't only see like
you know
it happens if you watch if you don't
listen to the bad guys if you watch the
podcast you know I lean in literally I'm
leaning into democracy every single day
leaning into the microphone and the
camera
oh boy we got a lot of [__] to round up
there's a lot of videos
outside the January 6th select hearing
but there was a lot of videos inside of
it
so I want to show a few of those before
we go to
bonehead of the week so let's do this
let's start the countdown let's surf the
Tweety tweets and trendy trends
start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
round up all the Tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of the day
thanks for joining us here for the
shitless Roundup let's see I got a lot
of video going on here I'm trying to
find exactly the one I want to show you
first
um I believe I believe this is probably
one on the news hit and I haven't talked
about it much here on the podcast uh of
Alex Jones
he's he's been ordered by a jury to pay
almost one billion dollars
to the Sandy Hook uh parents the victims
of Sandy Hook because of his lies and
his defamation
I mean you know he reached the [__]
find out face of the [__] around Saga
that's literally what happened
now in true Alex Jones fashion he didn't
just
get this judgment placed on him without
being a vile piece of [__]
of course he's a vile piece of [__]
so he decided to live stream as they
were handing down their verdict and the
amount that he would have to pay
to these individuals now Alex Jones is
trying to hide his money right
of course he is
he's a piece of [__] he wants no
accountability for his actions
that's
how manga Works they don't want to be
accountable for any of their actions
so he decided to live stream the the
here are the the courtroom while they
were handing down these judgments
and he decided to not only
to lie but he
he
mocks the family still
this is why no one should take him
seriously
when he says oh I told I apologize to
them I apologized who gives a rat's
[__] ass what you did
who gives a rat's ass what you did
listen
when you when you take
the power
of your influence
and your speech
and you use it to defame and to damage
someone
it is no longer
speech of freedom
it is speech of consequence
and you have the freedom to say almost
any goddamn thing you want to in this
country
more in this country than almost any
other around the world
but what you don't do
and what you don't have in this country
is freedom from the consequences
of the speech that you puke out of your
mouth
just like I have a set I had a seven day
ban on YouTube
you remember this a couple weeks ago we
were banned from YouTube some [__]
troll found a video from over a year ago
where I was mocking these [__] Q Anon
psychos at these school board meetings
yelling and screaming and puking up
misinformation into a microphone and I
was mocking them
YouTube did not like that
YouTube banned me for seven days from
posting
I tried my best
to get them to appeal
several times I appealed
YouTube told me no
that's just how it was
I didn't take out to social medium like
go to YouTube and tell them get them
over turn it and their blah blah blah
I'm being canceled
I just said the fact
and the fact was is that YouTube banned
me right wrong and different rather I
agreed or not whatever
it's their platform see
see
they get to decide
but when you use your influence
use your speech your voice
to damage someone
it's no longer
it's no longer your freedom of speech
I mean you can still say what you want
No One's Gonna Come handcuff you
but you don't get to live free of the
consequences this is the
problem that we have with white men in
this country
oh white men are the most depressed boo
[__] who white men are so oppressed
you know these guys you've met these
[__] there's one right here
he's gonna he's gonna mock
the parents of dead children who were
slaughtered
slaughtered by a lunatic who we as a
society because we can't get out in
front of policy
to make sure that lunatics don't receive
weapons of war
to carry into elementary schools and rip
little children apart
speaking of mass shootings there's
another one in the news not surprising
five people killed in Raleigh North
Carolina
but this [__] white male
oppression [__] is getting old
I have the right to say whatever I want
without consequence no you do not that
is not a thing
whether it's Financial consequences that
the court imposes on you or or you just
get your ass kicked
listen I'm I'm saying there is a lot of
these white male
souped up
McKees Mo [__] out there that
run their mouths use their freedom of
speech
and they put themselves in situations
where people just might not put up with
it
they just might not tolerate your
intolerance
and there's a lot of ways to handle it
in my neck of the woods when I was
growing up you would get your ass kicked
you get your ass kicked
now
do those consequences come with legal
ramifications of course
of course
but because you run your mouth it
doesn't mean you're free from
consequence
and Alex Jones is not free from
consequence of running his mouth
and the jury kicked him in the [__]
teeth here now he's trying to skirt
around he's going to try to hide his
money it is probably not going to work
folks
it's not gonna work for him I wouldn't
imagine and and really honestly he's
going to spend a boatload of money just
trying to run away from this
the gross thing is is that really in
reality it is probably his sick demented
delusional supporters who will bail him
out of this
and by bail him out of this I mean it'll
take a lot of years
for him to get back to where he has a
pile of money again
he will run on fumes for a long time
but my guess is is that over time
his audience these vile [__]
because they've been proven to give to
gross vile causes
that they'll bail him out over a period
of time
but Alex Jones will be broke for a long
time over this maybe the rest of his
life hopefully we can only hope
for what he's done to these few parents
of these children who were slaughtered
by spreading lies and defaming them and
and not only that but encouraging
I don't give a [__] what you say he was
encouraging his supporters by spreading
the lies that he knew were [__] wise
falsehoods misinformation
about these people about how it was fake
and how the some of these children
weren't even real get [__] out of here
that nonsense and let me tell you
something I don't care how much this
jury awarded these parents no [__]
amount of money no [__] amount of
money no 57 million 48 million
is worth any of those children to be in
their family's arms today
I don't care how much money it is
I don't care how much of Alex Jones
money it is I don't care how much it
destroys him even to me I would much
rather those parents have their children
today
than to be talking about how this is
going to financially destroy Alex Jones
and that's the difference
between decency
and intolerance
and you're going to see some gross via
[__] here in this video because he is
mocking the parents but never forget
this [__] because let me tell
you something he's gonna be broke for a
long time but he will be back
he will be back
even if he goes to jail in prison for a
while
because there's gross vile [__]
out there that are willing to support
these pieces of [__] watch this it's
gross thousand dollars 57 million 20
million 50 million 80 million 100
million blah blah you get a million you
get 100 million you get a 50 million
thousand dollars 57 million 20 million
50 million
he's a gross piece of [__]
he's a gross vile piece of [__]
and he's getting everything that's
coming to him
because he just can't help
but live inside of a lie speaking of
that
look at this guy speaking of Lies now
there's lying [__] right here
you guys know who this is this is Devin
Nunes he has a cow yeah Diamond Nunez
has a cow
and uh
it's a digital gal it's a virtual cow
listen Devin Nunes is a former
Congressman he gave up his congressional
seat to go commit crime for true self
showing be the Fall Guy
but Devin Nunes is um
is blaming the Trump documents raid on a
lot of different things it's kind of
weird listen but I think this actually
goes back pre-russiagate hoax I think
this goes back to the IRS scandal where
they targeted conservatives I think it
goes back to Fast and Furious during the
Obama Administration where they ran guns
and tried to set people up you remember
and then in America killed it goes back
to Benghazi they got away with that all
of this stuff is intertwined and then
you just fast forward you know cash
mentioned you know the Whitmer case and
Gen 6 and whether or not federal agents
were involved in that
so you just stair step and then
ultimately this leads to what this leads
to something never done in American
history before you had a president's
home ransacked by the same goons that
were involved in all of this
he's not a president okay he's not he's
not a president he's a former guy he's
not a president the president United
States home didn't get ransacked the
president United States is Jill Biden
there was no there was no sitting
president had their home ransacked you
dumb [__] and what in the actual
[__] does Benghazi
have to do
with Donald Trump committing crime what
on God's [__] Green Earth
I have never in my life dreamed
that these stupid bastards would they're
like Planet evidence no they're his it's
his staff
he stole it out right so it's his
possession is nine tenths of the law
just stupid [__] arguments stupid ass
[__] well he could declassify stuff with
his mind I mean just the dumbest
arguments we've heard about this
classified documents where how he's
going to be indicted he's going to be
indicted for stealing classified
documents
he will trust me they didn't go radius
home
and and take back their [__] after he
said nope I don't have any of it
under the guys of the Espeon object and
obstruction if they're not going to
charge him it's not a thing Merrick
Garland's gonna do
you're gonna see it he's listen listen
to me listen
October 14th
p.m eastern time Tony Michaels is saying
Trump will be indicted on the documents
case
Hondo persento
it's already we've already seen it the
Supreme Court is not willing to
capitulate to his crimes
they're not going to do it they're going
to let him they're going to send him out
to pasture with Devin nunes's cow
oh my God Benghazi really Benghazi
that's the best you got come on the
[__] mind control the mind
declassification was a way better that
was a way better [__] delusion than
Benghazi Devin Nunez Jesus [__] are
you kidding me
oh man where do they get these
[__] where do they get these
[__] I guess
in the Republican caucus is where you'd
find them hmm
um so I'm gonna play this uh video here
I'm not gonna play the sound and you can
go play the sound if you want I'm
actually afraid that YouTube might ban
me again over this video if I play the
sound I don't know
this is what Donald Trump's response was
to the January 6 Select Committee
subpoena him you watch it here he posts
a q Anon video
I'm not [__] is just packed full of
all these conspiracy theories like
Benghazi
Fast and Furious
Dominion machines
000 2500 mules or whatever it is oh it's
2 000 meals
I didn't know obstruction no collusion I
mean it's just continuing on with this
nonsense there was election fraud it was
stolen for me all this just [__]
they even you can see here Rachel
manners on this clip they even cut her
up in the clip to make it sound like
to make it sound like she's in support
of this narrative that it was a peaceful
rally and none of those people
were part of the rally and it was too
far away they cut that [__] up clip up
to make it
to make it uh you know sound in his
favor he's even trying to make Rachel
Maddow on his side that's how desperate
he is and so desperate cubanon is
but they do oh they do a bang-up job
really making it seem like this is a
real argument but he posted this [__] he
literally posted this Q Anon conspiracy
clip on fraud social as a rebuttal to
them sending our voting to subpoena him
to the January 6th Select Committee
which he won't go to
he's not going to appear he's not going
to comply with the subpoena and the
reason why is because he really he can't
number one
he can't because what he's going to do
is he's going to come plead the fifth
right
and the real problem that these folks
have with pleading the fifth in front of
the select committee is the select
committee gets to out them for that
the select committee they're not a
criminal investigative body
they're not investigating crimes that
they're going to charge for so they're
not going to charge for any crimes right
so they can actually say out loud well
they pled the fifth
when you're in a criminal
trial it's a little different with the
Fifth Amendment right
because you you don't have to
self-incriminate
especially when you're being charged
with a crime but these people yet are
not charged with a crime and they're
they're pleading the fifth
so when you see Roger Stone
and Mike Flynn and others
either using their Fifth Amendment
privilege or executive privilege
that says something
that gets at guilt
and we certainly can use that for sure
um Gabe Sanchez also pointed out here
about his response
and Trump I'm not gonna we'll probably
read it during the [__] list Army excuse
me the the bonehead of the week because
he was on the bone end of the week pole
for you know why
um but Gabe says you're Trump quoting
why didn't Liz Cheney invite me to the
January 6 hearings
and Gabe says my guy the whole show has
been about you
the invitation was implied the whole
thing the whole thing is about you
trying to steal our election
that that's what the whole thing was
about I mean if you really wanted to
protect your innocence maybe you should
have just showed up I mean that could be
a thing since you like to show up at the
Capitol when you're not invited anyways
hmm maybe you could have showed up then
I want to show you
um though this is this is a staggering
video
from the good liars
they do such a wonderful job but this
demonstrates to me it demonstrates
how easy it is
for Trump
to convince these [__] these
Trump supporters of wild ass [__]
very easily
they're easily convinced
there's not much guard up with these
people
there's just not Gabe Sanchez have you
watched this video of the good liars
here
I I would be able to hear you but uh the
uh your microphone geez Louise that
phone booth it's just it's so quiet that
I can't even hear you you know it's I
thought I thought the phone with it was
good enough for Superman it was good
enough for me
and unfortunately preparing yourself
dude I had to pay to use this phone
booth today Superman can go in any phone
booth you want did Superman have to rent
a phone booth did he have to go in and
throw a few quarters in the because you
know pay phones used to yeah he had to
put you know coins in them I for all you
folks out there that don't know what
coins are you had to put coins in these
in the little metal things they're like
tokens instead they're kind of round
yeah right right no no no no no no I had
to I'm not comparing myself uh but this
is this is a deep State phone booth here
this is a an underground deep State
don't know where it is I've been
blindfolded just come thrown in a van
and then I was shown up to a location I
don't know but they said look you got to
get on the show today you got to do
bonehead of the week that's right we
can't tell you where you're going so oh
okay that's just that's just what
happens when you're part of antifa you
get tossed around throwing an unmarked
van thrown into a phone booth and right
I'm I'm I've got these windows here I
don't even know what building I'm in
right now what see here's the thing the
cupcake and cookie get-togethers those
are a thing that is a privilege of being
an antifa but sometimes you just don't
know what deep State phone booth you'll
end up in or did you bring your soda
stream with you to the phone booth no no
this is regular tap water oh my God I
know I know it's a rough day in the Deep
State phone booth over there then huh no
luxuries of so here look at the end of
the day this is as I messaged you
earlier I said the things I do for for
democracy yeah and the random Bone boots
I'm thrown into the random commentary I
do it's always you all watching and for
those fighting for democracy
I I'm beginning to think that you're not
actually in a phone booth I think this
is Gabe AI okay so um speaking of
artificial intelligence are just
intelligence or lack thereof in general
this video here from the good liars is
is a prime example of how these people
are so easily convinced because a lot of
times people like how do these people
believe this stuff but it is it this
time people believe in Santa Claus I
don't know well right but this this
video demonstrates how easily how easily
you can circumvent their rationale and
their logic as long as you appeal to
what their narrative is right right as
long as you can make whatever
[__] that you're gonna puke out
fit their their beliefs and their
narrative in their timeline they're all
for believing it watch this this is It's
kind of incredible actually yeah oh you
know like queuing on the conspiracy
theory okay so if you see if you see the
good liar shirt there it says Biden JFK
Jr 24. so which is actually it actually
makes sense right right if you were to
be like well the politics of Jacob Jr it
actually line up with that bite him but
yeah right right I mean if if JFK Jr
actually was alive and he was running as
vice president he would be on this
ticket right like this would be the
ticket he would be on but here's the
thing so you see this shirt
maybe we should make our own Biden like
Biden Michael Jackson 2024 because they
believe all kinds of these people are
[__] alive are biting Tupac 2024 I
don't know
it's weird as [__] but um but this shirt
is implying that JFK Junior who is dead
who is [__] dead that we know of what
he's he is he is way dead like a lot now
man I don't know I've seen this dude
I've seen this dude at these Trump
rallies he says JFK Jr he got a nose job
oh my God I wish I had the video handy
um there's
there's this great account on Instagram
uh called crackhead and she she runs
around and there's one where she
approaches that guy that you're talking
about he's got a water bottle and she's
trying to get his trying to get a drink
of water and he's like here you can just
you just have the whole thing thanks
scurries away it's hilarious anyways uh
so if anyone goes and checks that out
but but this shirt is implying that JFK
Jr who is [__] dead is gonna run with
Biden in 2024. now it's a funny shirt to
us because we know the Nuance of this
right like we understand that JFK
Junior's dead but even if he was alive
he would probably run with Biden so you
know we like immediately we get the the
idea of this shirt watch what happens
when this Trump supporter is confronted
with why this shirt is the way it is
it's [__] unreal
to make sure you're not one of those
other there's a conspiracy theory that
like JFK Jr still alive you've heard
that before yes I heard of that and then
he's actually working with Biden in the
white house now okay now I know what
you're doing yeah
see now now he knows now he's got it
he's got it see
I haven't seen this video I'm gonna make
a guess there's two two options one is
he's working with Biden to take Biden's
Administration down and [__] on it so
that Trump can come in and be the savior
is that uh Biden is actually Trump in
Disguise and JFK Jr is going to run out
of ticket with actually Trump so it's
part of the Face-Off Conspiracy Theory
what what so those are all really good
theories I mean if I was gonna make a
movie
or mock these people those would be good
ideas oh it gets much dumber than that
it gets way dumber than that gets way
dumber than that you think how in the
[__] how in the [__] could it be any
dumber than Face-Off Style movie
Hollywood trumped up [__] nope I'm
telling you it gets Dumber watch this oh
JFK was on our side for president Trump
originally I thought that but then if
you if you go back and you do your
research JFK Jr was actually a Democrat
and so was JFK so now people are saying
he's actually working with Biden so
they're they're actually yeah so like
they they're actually working together I
heard Alex Jones say anything about that
one yet
[Laughter]
I told you I told you against Denver and
you really you really you doubted me
even through this this clip until the
Alex Jones part you doubted me the point
the point at the camera I think that got
me the most he goes I haven't heard that
one from Alex Jones yet like Alex Jones
or if you're listening if you're
listening holy actual [__] wow so
wow he did not give away where he gets
his ideas at all I mean he definitely
did not show his cards on where he
thinks these these ideas come from the
best part is this ending the ending is
uh fantastic here you see they're posing
for a picture here listen listen to the
to the audio and then JFK Jr 2024.
are you in the shirt
Heat I just it to me
you know it's funny it's funny that you
know that that but to me when I watch it
I'm like
I I know so many people like this like I
know them I grew up in the town where
there's just like you go into a public
place
and there's gonna be at least a dozen of
these guys like that's just what it is
can you go back really quick yeah keep
talking but I just want to show just a
freeze frame that they have on the right
okay yeah keep keep talking and I'll
point out after
so so the um which Freeze Frame do you
want Oh no just the beginning I want to
show the this ambulance that somebody
purchased oh I see I see or Trump save
the USA which is funny because Trump and
the Republicans try to gut any sense of
Health Care Medicare or anything we have
to actually help save in terms of the
health care side of this country which
is failing or which is not great but
could be better and it's mainly because
the Republicans have tried to remove it
and strip it away of all of its benefits
I just find it funny that not only that
but they've got these speakers that are
wired up to the top I'm assuming three
on that side through another those are
probably lights in between those
speakers like this thing is like a rave
Trump just like mobile kind of machine
is what it looks like it's pretty cool
you got to admit I mean yeah if you want
to have a seizure you know
it's just it whenever whenever I see
[__] like this Trump saved USA and it's
made out of a [__] ambulance it's
like one who who who bought this come on
guys like who the [__] paid for this
ambulance and two
I'm also curious what the inside is like
because I'm sure they've retrofitted it
into some Mega Man Cave
inside type mobile is what I had it's
what I have to guess I don't know
are you okay with the the ambulance now
are you can we yeah you know I just
wanted to that was a that was the first
can we move on yeah no I just wanted to
bring it up because I saw that and I was
like we haven't commented on this but
this is how ridiculous this group is but
yeah well but but here's the thing
here's the thing is that there are so
many ridiculous things in this [__]
video oh yeah even the stupid shirt that
the guy who's like wait he's confused
just like JFK Juniors with Biden wait
why tell me this I haven't heard Alex
Jones say this yeah they're totally down
to hear the conspiracy theory like yeah
I've heard that one before I haven't
heard that one before right I haven't
heard Alex Jones say that yet like
literally literally what the guy is
saying and in this video what what
strikes me the most is that what he's
saying is I don't believe it at first
glance because it really doesn't fit my
my current narrative which is that JFK
Jr is with Trump even though JFK Jr is
[__] dead that's the truth and again
the truth would be that JFK Jr would not
even be near Trump or be with Biden but
at first glance he's he's very skeptical
he said one of those and he doesn't
really say that I don't know if they cut
it off or what but he doesn't say what
they are one of those are but then he
basically admits if Alex Jones would be
willing
to say this into a microphone
oh he's all in he's all for this somehow
it might be like a conspiracy theory
that you said like oh JFK Jr is going to
go take him down or or Biden Dives and
then JFK Jr becomes president and makes
Trump the president and then he resigns
and trumps the prison I mean this is the
delusional [__] man I mean my I I don't
know if it's because I've read all of
these theories and so I'm like oh yeah
it's this like reverse double uh like
Play It's like a double agent kind of
thing like you thought it was good but
really bad but he's actually good on
your side
it takes a lot of mental energy to try
to rationalize or make logical sense but
I like how they're like oh no he just it
turns out yeah he's a Democrat and now
he's working with it like that makes
actually the most sense because they're
not trying to justify JFK Jr being some
crazy right-wing nut they're like oh
yeah he's actually a Democrat turns out
he's working with Biden crazy but that's
the truth and the truth
sometimes sounds crazier than the
made-up conspiracy theory right well and
and again it's all only to fit their
narrative right right and as long as you
appeal to what they want to be true
because that's what Trump's doing like
when he goes out in front of his crowds
and he's like oh we just need to have
another election we need to redo the
election or whatever [__] just just
just the dumbest [__] that you possibly
can think of that he says in front of a
microphone and it gets worse and worse
every American first Nazi rally that we
have
but the reason why he says it is because
he knows they want to believe it right
so if he if he in this case is Alex
Jones in this scenario just says it into
the microphone then they believe it they
believe it it's like this dumb stupid
theory that he's gonna be the speaker of
the house and that's going to create
this way for him to be president like
what the [__] are you talking listen if
Nancy Pelosi is evil as you say and
she's the speaker of the house and she
has been a couple times she would have
already been president like she would
have already done that thing right she
was so power hungry she's so demonic as
you claim and and the speaker of the
house had the power to just become the
president
don't you think she would have already
done that I mean here's the thing I
would almost argue that on January 6th
she was the president
well you know there wasn't anyone else
willing willing to defend democracy or
or which was one of my favorite things
in the world punch a Nazi she was sweet
she was like I also really you know the
punching and Nazi thing I think is an
interesting thing to bring up because a
lot of people are like oh you don't you
know like or rather liberals condemn
violence or they you know they don't
condone violence and they're now talking
about how they're going to punch a Nazi
if you are taking the stance that you
should not punch a Nazi even if you do
condemn violence and you're like well
that's hypocritical you guys are saying
you could dead violence but you are okay
with punching a Nazi if you're trying to
defend the Nazi and say well not Nazi
should not be punched in the face look I
don't fight people and I obviously
condemn violence but if a Nazi if I saw
Nazi get hit in the [__] face I would
say yeah that shit's hilarious because
it's called [__] Karma and you're a
shitty human being and those people who
are vile who want to strip away people's
rights want to kill people want to do
terrible things I mean it's almost as if
we've forgotten in the past two world
wars Nazis are bad people
if you see a video of somebody [__]
punching wait wait breaking news
breaking news if anyone didn't know we
had these world wars and there were
these terrible [__] people called
Nazis there was an even worse person
with a little mustache called Hitler he
was [__] terrible he was oh this is
great this is great this is great I have
I have a I have a story about a Hitler
mustache this morning my wife is out
garage sailing she sent me a picture of
Ann and coulter's book someone at the
garage sale had with a marker put a
Hitler mustache on and off
when the mustache fits
so when I hear people who are like oh
you know typically it's if you ever hear
somebody go wait you guys said this and
we shouldn't do violence but now you're
saying that hitting a Nazis okay if
you're that person if you're the one
defending the Nazi and trying to be like
well guys what are you you're I'm trying
to you know they're trying to call it
the hypocrisy there it's like you should
stop yourself right there on your track
before you say anything else actually
you know what dig yourself a ditch even
deeper because literally what you're
saying is the people who are Nazis who
want to kill people take people's rights
away you know [__] Hitler sterminate
exterminate exterminate you're okay with
that person we're saying they don't
deserve the actions that are a
consequence of what they said or did
that's what that's what you're that's
what those people are arguing and I
think you're right here is [__] dumb
and it's a dumb take to take but you
know what those people will continue to
do that and I say [__] it fine right
well here's the thing is that here at
the Tony Michaels podcast and I know
Gabe feels the exact same way we are
intolerant of intolerance we will not
tolerate it it's not a thing that we're
going to do we're not going to hide away
from we're not going to shy away from it
we're not going to be a punk ass [__]
and not appear before a select committee
because of the subpoena because you're
scared for incrimination which brings us
Gabe to the bonehead of the week
what uh what a bonehead of the week I
knew exactly who was gonna did you know
who was going to win of course I mean
here's the thing you know whenever this
person racism is on the list he will 100
win sometimes it's pretty close with
other people but other times it's a
[__] Landslide like if there was ever
a time when it's like hey I'm competing
against this person in a race he will
actually win this we don't need to have
fake electors we don't need to talk
about election fraud or how voters came
dead voters were voting
attempts
McDaniel dropped that in our lap
yesterday where she admitted yeah they
were trying to make me and the rnz do my
coup attempts it was really weird so
let's do yeah go ahead go ahead no I was
just gonna say you know uh this is one
of those races or those election you
know whatever you want to call it where
he doesn't have to cheat he wins flat
out it's a safe and fair election
and again 100 well they well the
audience voted they decided so we better
get to the results here yeah let's do
this we're gonna go to break when we
come back your favorite segment of the
week bonehead of the week from the phone
booth so we're gonna do bone hand of the
week from the phone booth everyone stick
around don't go anywhere bone end of the
week right when we return stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
break
favorite segment of the week no question
hands down
best segment we got because you vote you
decide
we go through who is the bonehead of the
week Abe Sanchez bonehead of the week
from the deep State phone boothy
[Music]
oh boy I don't think we should waste any
time because I got a lot of Clips to
show in this bonehead of the week and
we've only got uh well we've only got
about 45 minutes left here let's do it
we're gonna have to tick through the
bone of the week so stick around through
the song we'll get the bone of the week
right after the sound
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week Brown and Brown a
brown hand off the wink welcome to this
edition of bonehead of the week where
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week me and my co-host Gabe
Sanchez break down the bonehead of the
week every single Friday in the second
hour of the Tony Michaels podcast and
also replaying every single Friday on
the Midas touch Network so don't forget
to watch our show every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and also watch the replay of
bonehead of the week on the Midas touch
Network so subscribe if you right now if
you're on the Mindless touch Network hit
that button it's really easy but also
subscribe to our show the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube You're Not Gonna
Wanna Miss a Thing also to vote Gabe you
gotta subscribe to our podcast that's
where you find the poll also go to
Twitter later at Tony Michaels pod
that's where you will find the bonehead
of the week every single week we do not
rig elections we do not free and fair
here at the Tony Michael's spot and
they're safe they're safe safe elections
save elections you can also download
bonehead of the week and our show every
single weekday on Apple Spotify Google
don't forget to leave us a great review
while you're there subscribing on your
favorite directory
also if you're out there Gabe this thing
has been going like hotcakes we've sold
several of these already this morning
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty hoodie
zip-ups it did it's a zip ups and we got
pull over hoodies we also have T-shirts
there's coffee mugs oh my God hotcakes
they're going over there people like
Liberty they do like Liberty for some
reason people like democracy and Liberty
is a funny thing so go to
store.thetonymichaels.com to check out
the Liberty design
store.thetonymichaels.com guess what
Gabe you can use the promo code podcast
right now to get 10 off your entire
order just use the promo code podcast
that's a secret here
so you're hearing it right here so
subscribe to the Johnny Michaels podcast
go to store.d20michaels.com use that
promo code podcast for 10 off your
entire order
we got some real boneheads this week oh
yeah and some obvious ones really I mean
it's not hard to see that these three
white dudes
let's be specific here these are uh
not just three white boneheads right
these three white males these are subpar
lower than mediocre white dudes that
were in the running when I made the when
I made this graphic today I was like oh
look at these three white dudes so
[__] below average
oh and of course I believe is this Ron
Johnson's first time I had to yeah I
made this graphic this morning I cut out
his face you know I found what I believe
was a good photo and when I say good I
mean not good photo uh I always try the
exact picture Ron Johnson deserves by
the way yeah yeah 100 it's the uh it's
always the photo where I'm like do they
look sad angry confused dumb like all of
the basic emotions that I feel like
right you probably send out most of the
time right
they are oppressed white men you know
right
self-proclaimed self-uppressed white men
so why are these [__] boneheads on
this pole anyways uh let's start with
Jim Jordan because Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan is always at the top
of the bonehead list he's been has he
won bonehead before I don't know don't I
don't think so I mean like like he's
only did something yesterday about real
America again yeah he knows real America
yeah can't afford gas groceries or rent
when will the January 6 committee
address those issues well dumb [__] the
January 6 committee is about I know this
is going to be really hard to understand
but it's about the January 6th [__]
riots right that he helped that he
helped he even even was checking on
pardons to see if people are gonna get
people he was like hey can I get a quick
update on Pardons and you're like wait
why would you need a quick update what
the [__] are you doing he may want to
grab a pardon blanket I don't know I'm
just saying yeah he may Jim Jordan may
need one here's the Tweet here that he
sent out yesterday it was in it was in
the um it really so I thought you were
talking about a different one because I
have another point I want to bring up as
well what he other tweeted but he has a
tendency to talk about real America
which we've also talked about which is
like what is he tweets he tweets this a
lot fake America oh you were thinking
you were thinking of the one because he
did this several times yesterday but
you're talking about the one that
originally set it off which was the um
the the January 6th one that you
mentioned before right so he had one
yesterday that was about to talk about
real America can't afford gas grow she's
a rent but then you know because the
internet uh will fact check you in real
time they said hey Jim Jordan how about
you shut the [__] up about this gas [__]
because at the end of the day
you are the one who voted against the
oil and gas price gouging bill that was
proposed you were one of the 207 people
203 Republicans of the 207 that voted no
so when when he comes in and says when
will we talk about the real America in
these issues
no one like Jim Jordan can talk which
means most Republicans because they will
complain about something and then not
actually vote in favor of the thing that
helps relieve this stress or issue that
they're complaining about and this is
just one example so you know of course
because yesterday was all January 6th he
figured he could get on the trends and
he tweeted this during during the
hearing right exactly this during the
hearing so he was watching it obviously
it's yeah it so it's just another
example of Jim Jordan the Republican
Party complaining about some issue not
proposing actual Solutions and when you
know Solutions are put forward by the
Democratic party to say hey why don't we
try to control the way in which gas
prices are are dictated so we don't have
this price gouging that happens you know
whether there's stress on the system we
can you know find ways not to pass the
buck on to the consumer the Republicans
go yeah that was a good one you almost
had us on that one right but consumers
can go [__] themselves right well I mean
the only the only Lee the only party
that has done anything for real America
to afford gas groceries or rent
is the pro-democracy party that's the
only one
because they are the anti-party of
everything the Republicans anti
anti-everything so Jim Jordan can really
really go [__] off
what was your tweet that you were
showing
um the other one yeah the other one
here it is
is this real
if it is yeah here's the thing even if
there's no no I don't this is fake this
is fake this is fake but yeah but can
you believe that it is real
you know at first glance I was like yep
that is totally definitely say that in
in something he would say but no that
just shows you that just shows you how
shitty it's like you know it's it's it's
like the way in which I do the press
releases for Trump which I haven't done
one in a while but you know well yeah
because we almost we almost can't do
those anymore
yeah and the reason why is the reason
why is because he has gotten so [__]
crazy and so steeped in Q and on like
like
people even question the real ones now
they're like yeah I mean yesterday how
many documents was the one yesterday
that he released like 14. oh I don't
know the thing that was the craziest to
me was the [__] Q Anon video he post
a q Anon video and inside the video
there's this part with Rachel Maddow
where they clip this up to and I'm not
gonna show it because it is a q Anon
video now I posted it on our YouTube
channel if you want to now I put a
disclaimer that it is a q Anon clip like
I I didn't just post the video I said
it's a q Anon clip it is a conspiracy
video but if you want to go go see it
just go to Tony Michael's podcast on
YouTube just search Johnny Michael's
podcast it's there it's the one where
The subpoena clip but he posted a
conspiracy theory video and and it Clips
up Rachel Maddow to make Rachel Maddow
sound like she's in support of trump is
really [__] weird it's really weird
it's man come on really honestly I don't
know yeah you know but let's get back to
the boneheads because I got some more
clips of the boneheads here Ron Johnson
Ron Johnson Putin this guy who who only
said
uh I guys look I only code for like a
few minutes on January so like that
shouldn't really count against me I was
praying I just got swept up and yeah I
tried to pass off these fake electors to
get pens to sign off on them but it was
I only carried those documents for like
a mere three minutes hey guys I cooed
any longer than I lasted that's exactly
that's exactly the argument that that
Ron Johnson is saying he's like look
guys it was three minutes that's way
longer
than I do in bed okay that's like an
eternity well the guy with the last name
Johnson trying to trying to have big
dick energy you would expect it from him
here he is at the debate this is why we
I wanted him on the bone in the list our
bonan of the week list was because of
the debate he had with Mandela he was he
was a late entry last night let me tell
you something he had some zingers I mean
he had the audience slapping their knees
now they weren't laughing at him or with
him we were laughing at him yeah they
were laughing at him because he said
some crazy ass stupid [__] like this one
here
something about the FBI set up and it
sounds more like Planet documents and
mind control Declassified type [__] like
it is like Biden JFK Jr in 2024 type
stuff here here is here's the conspiracy
theory that he's trying to sell and the
audience does not buy it in response to
the wild charge of a lieutenant governor
Barnes the FBI set me up with a corrupt
with a corrupt briefing and then leave
that to smear me I am
you have to shut the [__] up I'm sorry
this is embarrassing this is really
embarrassing I love how
whoever was controlling the sound
they're like nope cutting them off we're
done we're done we're done as soon as
you brought in the FBI and you were
being framed for something it was like
nope that wasn't even the question
because obviously there isn't I think
you're gonna play the other clip that
they asked them both they asked them a
question and Ron Johnson takes an
opportunity to
go his own path with it right well I
mean a lot of times in these debates
because they say a lot of mean [__]
right yeah because gay people we know by
the former guy posting on fraud social
that people are mean people are just
mean I mean it's okay it's okay if
they're mean yeah it's okay if they make
fake nicknames and are racist and our
bigoted but if we get it turned on them
that's that's people being mean them
aren't they're really not people
yeah so I don't know maybe that's what
their logic is but during these debates
you say a lot of stuff right a lot of
accusations get thrown around so
traditionally at one of these debates
what the moderators do at the very end
is say hey you said a lot of
nasty [__] about your opponent how about
you say one nice thing just one just one
nice thing politics it's dirty it can be
ugly people get their names smeared and
dragged through the mud
maybe maybe let's try something a little
different here we end this thing or try
to try to bring it to a close with a
nice thing to say a nice thought like
that's let's just be decent humans
decency has seemed like a low bar in the
past but with the Republican party of
today it is a high bar to reach for and
here's a prime example of it all right
we are down to one final question here
and both of you have said a lot tonight
about each other now when we traveled
around the state talking with voters we
heard repeatedly from people tired of
divisive politics and attack ads so our
final question here tonight is both of
you have been successful in life you
have 30 seconds here Mr Barnes you go
first what do you find admirable about
your opponent
okay so there's the question what do you
find admirable and the reason why they
want to answer this question is you
heard they travel around the state and
the one thing that the voters the people
who are going to vote for one of these
two people
keep that in mind Ron Johnson heard
those words
that the voters said well I'm tired of
the divisive politics and the name
calling and the mean talk
Mandela Barnes here takes the high road
he has class just as most liberal
Democrats it's also a very
straightforward question there is no
right gotcha moment there's no politics
of it there's no I mean there is
obviously a wrong answer the right
answer is just to say hey this person
like you could even say you know what I
like about this person they love
baseball and I love baseball too
literally they've got they've got a nice
smile even if they don't even if it's a
lot even if this is a lie you have
enough class to at least be like you
know
he shook my hand a little bit ago when
we came on stage and I guess that's
admirable like like even that just just
the the low bar of decency here now
Barnes goes beyond the bar of decency
obviously
um the low bar of decency very very low
right and he actually has some class
listen to what lieutenant governor who
is running for Senate
Mandela Barnes
well no no seriously I do think you know
the senator has proven to be a family
man and I think that's that's admirable
uh you know that's absolutely to be
respected he speaks about his family
he's done a lot to provide for them I
absolutely respect that
okay pretty good it seems like he even
went far enough to you know kind of look
into Ron Johnson's past to see that if
he was a family guy I mean I you know I
don't know that you would just say that
out loud if you didn't like just at
least do a little bit that yeah he's you
can say that out wow look it's you know
it's almost like Barnes knew this
question was coming almost right I mean
you know Susie bird brings up a good
thing here it's always a safe bet a
family man there's nothing wrong with
that especially since family is such a
big thing for anyone running politics
but specifically someone who's a
conservative they love their family love
spreading their [__] Offspring right
they love that easy answer easy
compliment that's it there's you can't
go wrong with that
well maybe don't okay this is bone end
of the week Gabe this is about another
week the family man thing the family
thing can go wrong very quickly all
right here's an example of that
Mr Johnson I mean likewise I appreciate
the fact that uh lieutenant governor
Barnes had loving parents a school
teacher father worked third shift so he
had you know good upbringing
there you go see the family man thing
see if I stop the clip there you'd
believe oh my gosh well this is one of
those moments where you would stop it
and fake Gabe would say please
on Facebook and yeah he likes to troll
in the chat and he likes to spread lives
around I haven't seen face here I'm
gonna be honest unless I unless I
haven't read the chat I don't think fake
Gabe has come back I think Texas Texas
Paul just [__] annihilating laid into
him
and if anyone hasn't seen that clip that
we have we haven't I think we have it on
YouTube right yes we do go to our
YouTube channel if you're not there
already subscribe
nuclear yeah and he went nuclear on
Tuesday in a good way and it was pretty
amazing the cussing Pond and it was
almost like we were right there
virtually at the cussing Pond but back
to Ron Johnson here so if if we stop the
clip there you would believe that hey
wow this is excellent they said great
things about each other but it is not in
there it doesn't Ron Johnson doesn't
stop there and you you said the family
man thing was a safe bet well here is
how you can really [__] that up listen I
guess what puzzles me about that is with
that upbringing why is he turned against
America I mean why why does he find in
finding America oh he was this close
somehow we did not I said we said
something admirable
so Ron Johnson does not know the
definition
what a [__] bonehead these clothes
almost can't work the third shift done
and he put all of it in there even
teacher third shift yeah
and he goes but with that being said and
you're like oh God no he even said
upbringing he was like upbringing which
like has religious kind of connotations
and
morality built into that kind of
phrasing he [__] up he could have he
could have [__] bone him easily
walked away and and that being the last
question could have been like oh okay
well you know Ron Johnson didn't end it
on a shitty note and Ron Johnson was
like Yeah hold my beer guys right let me
just let me just how can I ruin this
debate even more for myself I'll go
ahead and just torch the whole thing and
of course the audience is just like oh
God Like Jesus dude you are gross like
even the audience is grossed out like
they were laughing at him there's a
couple
right do you know the deaf do we need to
get a dictionary we can dust one off can
you would like to retell the origin of
the word Admiral that's like a spelling
bee like adverbal okay uh
please you can use it in a sentence Oh
my God speaking of family men who like
to spread their family around all over
the Earth we have a dishonorable mention
today Elon Musk why did old Elon end up
on our dishonorable mention well we
found out Elon is now under
investigation
for his little Twitter deal uh oh you
know we've been saying from the very
beginning very it's been a big
controversy over me from the I mean the
day he announced that he was gonna buy
Twitter that he was never going to own
Twitter and and I'm still saying it Elon
Musk will never owned Twitter he will
never own Twitter it's not gonna happen
it won't happen this is proof right here
October 14th Friday
uh 1 37 p.m Eastern Elon Musk will not
own Twitter ever it's not going to
happen and here isn't a prime example
why because he's now under federal
investigation I believe right yeah what
is the actual what is the actual aim of
this investigation and what are they
this one is in regards to the Twitter
acquisition so this is uh basically he's
been I just want to put a picture up of
Elon Musk for reference here go ahead
yeah yep there we go that's him yeah uh
basically he's been investigated because
uh he pretty much [__] up
um it's federal investigation for the
Twitter deal
um says in a Twitter says in a court
filing Elon Musk is being investigated
by federal authorities over his conduct
in the 44 billion dollar takeover deal
for Twitter Inc the social media company
set in a court filing released on
Thursday while the filing said he was
under investigations it did not say the
exact focus of the probes were and how
in which the federal authorities were
conducting them so just to catch
everyone up what happened was Elon Musk
made a joke on Twitter he said oh should
I own Twitter right being the person who
wants to fight for the First Amendment
and all that [__] that he that the
right claims to have but loves to
suppress on others
so
he puts out a poll overwhelmingly people
say yeah yeah buy Twitter buy Twitter
buy Twitter now what I believe
originally started as a joke
required him to double down on a joke so
he didn't look weak and not an alpha
well not not the cuck he really is right
and so what happens is he has to double
down he offers 54-20 because it's a 420
joke which adds up to 44 or 45 billion
dollars that's so funny
then what happens is Twitter says all
right Ben we'll take the 44 billion
because why wouldn't we that's well
above market price we have an
obligations a due diligence a fiduciary
responsibility
to serve our shareholders that we make
them money so we and oh by the way if
you back out we're gonna charge you
almost at this point it's about 16
billion right right so the original deal
that said in there was like anyone who
backs out Twitter backs out or if uh
if uh Elon backs out there's a one
billion dollar Clause that says you owe
this money to the other party for
backing out now there's another thing
that's a performance clause in there and
that basically says like you agree to
the company and like if anything's done
you can't maliciously talk about them
this and that don't do that what she
ended up doing he was attacking
Executives he was [__] talking the
company about the Bots and all this
random stuff to try to get out of the
deal now this performance Clause
basically shows you it says Hey based on
when you agree to the price and if
things happen
and the price of that company let's say
goes down in value then you are also
responsible for the Delta of that so the
Delta of the of the what he the
difference was about 16 billion which
means he would owe an additional 16
billion so basically it was either a
billion 44 billion or 16 to 17 billion
in the grand scheme of either acquire
sounds like a pretty good deal on
Twitter yeah I mean Twitter's like well
I mean why wouldn't they take we could
anywhere from 1 billion to 44 billion in
it at the end of the quarter or the end
of the deal when this closes right
honestly like at the end of the day even
if they have to settle this out of court
they're still going to get at least a
billion bucks so what's what's the down
ball there's no winner no doubt no
downfall for Elon Musk pretending to own
Twitter for Twitter because Twitter gets
to get his money at the end of the day
and so then what happens is Elon tries
to get out of the deal by complaining
about Bots Twitter says fine we'll give
you an unfiltered data essentially a a
fire hose of data streaming in a bunch
of data to him they're going through it
and he's like all these Bots and not on
he's complaining about these issues to
get out of the deal right he's trying to
blame Twitter and say well they lied to
me and they didn't give me the full
information and they didn't reveal this
and that so then Twitter was like okay
dude you signed it you signed the
contract we gave you everything we were
we helped you every step along the way
and
we're just gonna sue you now so now in
all of these court documents they
revealed also in these text messages
that Elon was 100 he knew what was going
on he was completely serious in the
conversations he was having with Jack
Dorsey and other Executives these these
text messages have been revealed
publicly because they're dealing with it
in court right now and it's just
evidence that's on display
and now he's getting investigated it
looks like by federal authorities
because he's trying to [__] around with
the company and the company lost money
in its value and now he doesn't want to
pay so if you're doing that again there
are consequences for your actions it's
just like yeah you can say dumb [__] you
can say the dumbest racist bigoted stuff
online but guess what there are going to
be consequences for the things you say
it's just like you were talking about
earlier with Alex Jones you can say the
dumbest craziest most vile things
especially about victims in the in the
the parents of those victims from Sandy
Hook
however there's going to be consequences
which would be him owing nearly a
billion dollars in Damages and then him
doubling down and saying even more
disgusting stuff so when people like
that and Elon Musk say oh well first
amendment it's sure yeah go ahead but
there are going to be consequences when
you [__] around you're gonna find out
you are now in the find or out State
find about or found outstage you're
being investigated and Elon Musk and
it's not only that too we also then
earlier this week we found out from a
vice article that Elon Musk was uh in
conversations with Putin
like this is crazy you know and when you
have Elon Musk who's like I'm gonna set
up these starlink satellites for you
what is starlink for anyone who doesn't
know Elon Musk went to Ukraine to set up
startling right so starlink are the the
satellite service in terms to connect uh
he's got a bunch of satellites that
basically connect you know for for uh
internet
um coverage in different areas right and
so he says I'm going to put these
satellites over this area of Ukraine and
I'm going to allow people to get in
contact to call to what happens this
basically gives them access to the
internet where where Russians can't
really destroy this access to the
internet and so it's so because it's
this broadband internet connection it's
also low latency so it's it's a decently
fast connection
um and a relatively inexpensive it's
technology that he didn't invent but he
takes credit for because someone who
works for him invented exactly exactly
so he also Elon Musk type [__] right so
Elon Musk comes in as the Savior to say
hey guys I'm give giving you these
starlink satellites I'm going to put
them over this region to make sure that
you guys are able to actually connect to
the internet
then fast forward to just last week or
last weekend whenever the bridge to uh
Crimea was blown up
it pissed Putin off Big Time Putin was
like and he had a conversation with Elon
then Elon decided to tweet a map and how
to resolve the issue between Ukraine
it's yeah the the resolution is Russia
doesn't invade Ukraine it's as simple as
that you know uh Putin should not try to
commit genocide right there's no both
sides to this it's literally there's no
both sides dude
and committing war crimes killing
innocent women there's no both sides of
that don't don't commit the war crimes
don't try to commit genocide or commit
genocide and you won't have this issue
but as soon as this bridge is blown up
Putin is angry turns out there's a
conversation that Putin has with with
musk and now Elon Musk is shutting down
access to starlink
a little bit suspicious very odd
definitely you mean this is after he had
a conversation with Vladimir Putin on
how to resolve because this internet
connection is really crucial right now
with the communications of the Ukrainian
Army and and the Ukrainian Rebels that
are trying to fight with the ukrainians
um to fend off Russians
um and here's Dan is reporting here four
hours ago a senior U.S official Express
exasperation to me about this starlink
situation in Ukraine involving Elon Musk
now musk this is a quote dangles hope
over the heads a million this is what
they're saying about musk I think right
dangles hope over the heads of millions
then sticks the dod with the bill for a
system no one asked for but now so many
depend on so what happened was he said
I'll provide it for free I think he even
tweeted it which is kind of a pattern
here that he does something and then
doesn't follow when he's like hey how do
I help fight world hunger and people
said or what should I do and get people
said help fight world hunger and so he's
like all right fine what it'll take a
few billion four to five billion okay
cool and then the next thing he just
completely pivoted away from that and
was like I'm gonna buy Twitter right and
we've seen how that goes well again he
tweeted stuff out he doesn't follow
through and that's what he's doing at
Starling so he he he tweeted out I'm
gonna give them the internet for free
basically this is the greatest
technology ever that I'm taking credit
for for inventing that I didn't actually
invent someone who works for me actually
invented it because I'm an idiot and the
only people that are smart enough to
invent this stuff actually worked for me
it's not actually me
um but he basically what he did is he
installed this in Ukraine they're
relying on it now now what he wants to
do is to to charge the American DOD the
Department of Defense to have this
starlink system in Ukraine the richest
man on earth he's the richest man he you
know ain't gonna help you crank give me
a [__] break this guy is a joke he's
a liar he's a thief he's probably a tax
chief he's and he's probably committed
fraud a dozen times just just in the
little subsection of buying Twitter this
guy is Never Gonna own Twitter
and eventually you will see Elon Musk in
the find out phase of the [__] around
Saga you will find him there it's going
to happen so let's I I'd love to talk
about Elon for the remainder but we
gotta get to our bonehead
of course because we've got tons of
Clips to show
of people wanting to punch him I'm
literally literally I have a clip it's
not an exaggeration it's literally what
what Donald Trump drives people to do
they push people to their their [__]
limits and they'll say things like
if he comes here I'm gonna punch him I'm
gonna punch him out well he does have a
very I mean come on mostly Nazis it's
almost like he has a Target on his face
like just right in the [__] mouth
so Donald Trump was a big part of the
hearing yesterday matter of fact it's
almost like every hearing has been about
him I think you tweeted about this yeah
I was like I showed this earlier on the
show because it's true like at the end
of the day Trump wants to complain on
Truth social how oh they waited till the
very last moment to come to to invite
him to the Jan six Committee hearing the
unselect Committee hearing they waited
till the very last moment to ask for his
his you know his his testimony dude it's
been the [__] Donald Trump hour this
whole time like I said right treason
Hunters season two as I said my guy the
whole show has been about you the
invitation was implied it's built in
when the warning the time they invited
him to walk to the Capitol like no you
just yeah you can't we won't punch you
we promise if you just come in if you
just show up right just show up now but
here's the thing now he released he he
released a
a
14 pages of document of these pages of
like how the this whole thing is a sham
and the election is a fake and it's a
frauds boy and this and then he's your
president's [__] [__] 14 pages he
had a [__] rant from the desk of
Donald Trump like that's some sort of
like any truthful uh valid
Mark but this guy is so deranged so
unhinged so [__] insane that he
thinks that he should still be the
president he thinks he was cheated even
though even uh the former Attorney
General Bill Barr said it's [__] you
have people that literally told him he
lost and we learned yesterday that he
did acknowledge the fact that he lost
specifically one of the key points of
evidence was the fact that he signed an
immediately he pushed to have an
immediate release for the withdrawal
from Somalia in Afghanistan and when
they said well we can't do that
or we don't think that's wise he goes no
no not my problem it's for the next guy
to solve which is Biden so he he already
had acknowledged through these move
through the emotions that he put forward
that he was done he lost he already knew
he was a [__] loser and he said it
out loud but he wasn't willing to say it
out loud to the rest of his people that
he instigated to storm the capital
here is Jaime are asking letting loose
on the information that we that was laid
before the American people yesterday
went on MSNBC and let loose let's listen
means a lot to the members of the
committee and to our staff you know but
I would say this what kind of snowflake
is Donald Trump uh that he's willing to
send hundreds and hundreds of other
people to go and do his battle
um and to attack police officers with
Trump Flags in Confederate battle flags
and turn American flags into weapons and
he's very happy to do that and he won't
even come and explain himself why he
thought he had a right to do that or why
he thought that was the right thing to
do what is he afraid of
so there he is
um getting
um cucked by Jaime Raskin because this
is the truth he's a punk ass [__] he'll
never do it yeah and really our Alpha
[__] plays an important role in this
idea of the violence so the applicant of
the week is Roger Stone and that is
another piece of evidence that we
watched against Donald Trump and this
idea that he was going to overturn the
election because we know we know now
actually there's a video that MJ sent me
that I want to play first yeah there's a
new video yeah there's a new video this
morning of ryderstone our Alpha cook who
cucks for Donald Trump but here's
ronderstone is really short listen to
what he says at the end and we'll talk
about who it is that he's talking about
Jared Kushner has an IQ of 70. he's
coming to Miami
we will eject him from Miami very
quickly he'll be leaving very quick very
quickly
very quickly he has a hundred security
guards I'll have 5 000 security guards
you want to fight let's fight [__] you
[__] you and your abortionist [__]
daughter
wait wait does Jared Kushner have a dot
it could took me a couple times to
realize who he's talking about here he's
talking about Donald Trump yep he's
talking about Donald Trump and he's
using Jared Kushner
as this because they're gonna appear in
Miami yeah Kushner and he says your
daughter he means Trump and he's talking
about Ivanka Trump holy but this guy is
on the Chain this guy is an unhinged
gargling fascist he couldn't even get
the words he said oh God oh God
don't insult fascist okay I I mean I'm
dead serious this is this is some he is
a [__] lunatic dude and and I think
because we've seen the some of this
footage from this documentary right and
and we know we know that Roger Stone are
alpha cuck today was in communication
the entire time with Donald Trump
there's no doubt in my mind that these
two were on the phone just as Donald
Trump was now yelling and screaming at
each other over the phone and we've seen
footage of him talking about a lot of
wild [__] even the Steve Bannon where
he's talking to his Chinese accomplishes
were like right this is before the
election they're saying look it doesn't
matter what happens he's just gonna
declare that he's the [__] winner and
that's just how it's going to be and
that's and that's why what's going to
happen now yesterday though
there was a there's another piece of
footage where he's where he's saying
that uh uh people sessions nine tenths
of the law right right and that that and
this was on November 1st but the day
after is the new clip that we got now
he's walking what appears to be an
airport here that's what I believe that
this is It's a terminal somewhere and
he's gotta he's got a mask on and that's
why I think it's an airport because he
has to have a face mask on at the time
and it says Trump but listen to what he
says about voting and votes this is how
much Roger Stone believes in democracy
listen
I say [__] the voting let's get right to
the violence this is November 2nd 2020.
okay
this is November 2nd 2020. they already
knew before the election even happened
that hey Donald Trump is going to win B
that there was going to be violence and
see they were going to have to use it to
keep him president they knew that yeah
they knew it the entire time that's why
Roger Stone is why do we why are we
going to even vote who gives a [__]
let's just get straight to the coup part
let's just get straight to the violent
Coupe because we also saw on the other
Clips he get no possession is nine times
a law [__] you I won
and that's how he said that right that
Trump should go forward with it should
just declare he's like it'll probably be
pretty close you know obviously he's
seeing this as a potential issue and
says the only way to move forward is to
declare that you won if you've got
enough people to say you won you won you
won then it cast doubt in the election
and the system that we have participated
in as a free and safe and fair election
and by doing so
then you cause them to say well maybe we
have to do a redo or this or that you
know and then you and then we saw they
they did a tick tock of trump being told
through different interviews nope you
lost it's over right not just not just
not just the Department of Justice he
was told by several different people
that look it's it you're you've lost
it's done now we have
witnessed this big this is a famous
picture in history where Nancy Pelosi
looks I mean this makes it look like she
wants to punch him and really everyone
in the room it feels like the energy in
the room is that she is gonna come over
the table and punch him she's like I
will [__] come over this table and
drag you out on the steps myself like
that's the type of here's Nancy Pelosi
has like what five kids right she's a
mother she doesn't deal with this
[__] man she's [__] no I'm she's
like look I'm not gonna deal with you
adult you petulant child you're a man
babysitting in an oval office who got in
here even though you lost the popular
vote at the end of the day you're just a
whiny little [__] and I'm gonna call
you that so when you try to overthrow
the government like we saw in the video
on January 6th she's like I want to
punch him out I want to if he comes here
I'm gonna [__] punch him out well
here's here's the video
um now
this is a piece of footage that we have
not seen yet we did not we did not see
the footage of Nancy Pelosi and others
in the full extent of them asking
for the dod the Maryland Virginia
National Guard anyone any security force
that they could get to try to fend off
the shark army here that Grandpa
Poopypants
engaged at his little Nazi rally before
the counting of the electoral college
now and the certification now
again this is very rare that a camera
would capture this
um and it's very rare that we would even
get to see this kind of footage but
because of what the grandpa poopy pants
and the shark army did or tried to do to
our constitution our democracy is the
reason why we're seeing it and this is
just a little snippet of a seven minute
video that they played but this is the
thing that everyone's talking about on
the internet today and this is where I
say we got to be uh intolerant of
intelligence and really
punching Nazis shouldn't be a
controversial thing let's listen
they don't have the resources to protect
him here
so at the moment he is not coming but
that could change
okay so this is what they're talking
about we all know the story now of him
trying to get into the SUV and go to the
Capitol and they wouldn't take him so he
got in a scuffle and then when he got
back to White House he was a little
[__] that he is he was throwing his
ketchup in his hamburger against the
wall and he got upset but yesterday we
it was revealed that he was still trying
to go he's still trying to get the
secret service to take him to the
Capitol so he could crown him I'm not
really sure what the I don't know what
the purpose is there's no constitutional
mechanism that'll that allows him to
take maybe I don't know what he was
maybe he felt like if he showed up they
would like do this like coup crowd
surfing where they would just like jail
him up to the top
that's a lot of women the president it's
me you guys know big Donald right like I
feel like that's you know he he probably
wanted them to carry him up the steps
you know it could be it could be but I
can't figure out why he'd want to go but
he did he kept trying to go that day to
the Insurrection to the coup attempt so
that he could be crowned King I guess
right there live on TV I'm not sure this
guy who knows what this lunatic wanted
but listen to Nancy Pelosi's response
when she finds out that the [__]
was told not to come up there but he's
still trying to convince Secret Service
to come to the Capitol listen to what
she says
I'm waiting for this the trespassing
long attack will ground I want to punch
him out and I'm gonna go to jail
she didn't know she's like I'm gonna
punch him out yeah I'm gonna go to jail
but it's all [__] worth it because
this guy's again a petulant child who
will not give up and will complain and
complain and complain that he won the
election and it was rigged and it was
stolen and the [__] uh the smart
Matic and the Dominion voting machines
and all this dumb [__] cute
conspiracy [__] and she here right
in the real moment she sees the
recording she goes I want to punch him
out yeah I'm okay going to jail I want
to [__] punch him out like yeah in
the moment because she's just saying
this she forgot the cameras there
honestly yeah and then she she remembers
and she turns to the camera and says oh
by the way I know that I'll go to jail
yeah I get it but I'll be happy I will
be happy to go to jail if he comes up
here to punch him out this is the famous
moment this morning
um and really honestly it just shows the
difference in the leadership and if you
have a chance please go watch the seven
minute video now the footage from the
seven minute video it's super important
to see it but one reason why it is more
important than just
what happened in the moment it's about
what Republicans are saying now about
the Insurrection because I said this
morning Kevin McCarthy and Steve
scalise's leadership of the minority in
the house should resign today because
they are currently trying to cause an
Insurrection they are currently
insurrecting right now we should get the
14th Amendment out on their ass dust it
off and use it on them because they're
currently doing it I want to show you a
clip here this the comparison of what
Steve scalise is saying now versus where
he was at in the seven minute clip it's
very important watch was speaker Pelosi
involved in the decision to delay
National Guard assistance on January 6th
those are serious and real questions
that this committee committee refuses to
even ask
so he asked
and they delivered but here's Steve
scalise's take on it thank you Jim and
Jim Banks just raised some very serious
questions
that should be answered by the January 6
commission but they're not
they were answered yesterday Steve what
say you but let's let's watch let's
watch where he was at during this entire
thing and whose side he was by and
they're not for a very specific reason
and that's because Nancy Pelosi doesn't
want those questions to be answered in
fact she she literally she literally
brought the vote to the floor to create
the select committee to investigate it
she knew she was gonna have to hand over
this video footage where it talks about
where she says out loud if he comes here
I'm gonna punch him out they subpoenaed
that footage
okay they got that well they probably
didn't have the subpoena she was like
Hey look when you could read I got
something uh you're gonna love right
because here at the end of the day like
we saw that clip where she's literally
on the phone unfazed it's like girl I
need to call the mayor I need to call
the governor I need more troops I need
more Armed Forces I need to bring these
people in you heard Chuck Schumer you
know with his New York sassy comes in
you know he's talking he's like look we
need these people we need them now Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer like look we
don't care about the stuff in our office
it was ransacked it's destroyed we don't
care about that we care about the public
safety and the harm unto others
specifically those of uh that are
working there as capital police these
people are getting beaten by uh by huge
metal flag uh
rolling uh billboard kind of uh
Contraptions they're getting pushed
they're getting maced with Bearer spray
they're getting you know threatened with
guns these people are not just doing a
tourist visit at the Capitol these
people are trying to literally kill
others who stand in their way back to
Blue [__] that [__] they don't
actually back the blue and so when
you've got Nancy Pelosi again I said it
earlier in the show
she was more of a president than Donald
Trump on January 6. she was doing the
job that uh that Kevin McCarthy wouldn't
do that Mike Pence wouldn't do that
Donald Trump definitely would not do she
was the one who literally had the balls
in the situation to say we got to call
these people we got to figure out this
plan we need to make sure we clear these
people out and we have to get this vote
down to the floor because if we don't
then this thing is going to continue to
be a [__] show and yeah if he wants to
come down here I'll punch him out I'll
punch him out right now I'll go to jail
I don't [__] care Nancy Pelosi didn't
care she was like I need to do my job
and we need to make sure that we follow
through with our job as representatives
of the United States
well here is you're going to see the
evidence here after Steve scalise lies
to the American people in in real time
we're gonna see she took the
unprecedented step of kicking Jim Banks
and Jim Jordan off of the January 6
committee because they were going to ask
those questions not a lot of people
would like the answers to this cannot be
just we're waiting for so and so we need
them there now whoever you got
okay so this is footage that they showed
yesterday and it says on the
caption here Republican leaders Mitch
McConnell
Steve scalise and John thune joined
Democratic leaders to call Dod
now you don't see him in the footage
here but wait for it I'll show you okay
you also have troops this is true okay
Andrews Air Force Base all right okay
this lady here moves out of the way for
someone did you notice that game kind of
made room for someone to get closer to
the phone to hear the conversations
going on let's see who it is thank you
we need active duty National Guard how
soon in the future can you you see this
guy over here in the mask and the red
dye I know it's hard to figure out who
that is but that there is Steve scalise
God
what a piece of [__] trash he knows
he knows what he's saying is a lie he's
he's doing it intentionally and he's
doing it intentionally to undermine her
democracy he is trying to commit an
Insurrection another coup it is active
Kevin McCarthy Steve scalise are acting
with our Bonet of the week to to commit
another coup on our government our
elections and our democracy and they
must resign immediately I am calling for
Steve scalise and Gavin McCarthy to
resign those lying sacks of [__] and of
course there's a whole other list of
Republicans that could resign I mean
Jesus Jim Jordan Ron Johnson I mean the
list goes on and on and on here but we
do not have time to go through the
entirety of that list so let's do this
let's give the bonehead of the week his
due because he got out front and boy he
just took off let's give Donald Trump
the bone end of the week
let's watch it
[Music]
[Applause]
no contest
of the century for that matter I don't
know that anyone will ever hold a candle
to this guy everyone thank you for
joining us for moment of the week thank
you for voting for bone and the week
again if you want to vote for bonan of
the week follow us on YouTube the Tony
Michaels podcast subscribe there also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod you can vote every single week for
Monday of the week and we play the bone
of the week every single Friday every
one of them Gabe on the Tony Michaels
podcast and we replay it that night on
the Midas touch Network so check out the
replay there and if you're on the
Mindless touch Network watching the
replay make sure to subscribe right now
and also download every single moment of
the week on Sundays Apple Spotify Google
just go search the Tony Michaels podcast
while you're there while you're
subscribing on your favorite directory
leave us a great review and also visit
store.thedonymichaels.com we got a lot
of merch going on there here's a Rhonda
Santa's can go [__] himself that's about
we got the the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
the Liberty quote is hot hot gay we got
t-shirts coffee mugs zip up hoodies and
hoodies let's go check out
store.thedonymichaels.com
what a great bonehead of the week
everybody oh this has been your addition
a bone of the week if you're on the Tony
Michaels podcast stick around for just
one second
but if you're on the minus touch we'll
see you next week on bonehead of the
week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
we're over just a little bit here but I
guess we've been going over it they keep
saying three hours three hours I I mean
we went like two and a half yeah
yesterday we streamed for five four
hours you had to sit in that phone booth
I was here for yeah yeah five hours holy
moly I didn't go pee once I'm just
kidding while it was playing we took
some breaks
nah I'm just kidding I did I did eat a
few things while the hearing was going
but what are you hearing yesterday I
mean it was it it felt like I I I I was
gonna start a list but I'm like nah I
can keep track of it but there's just no
way to keep it I know I've gotta I've
gotta go through I'll do what was that
on uh on this on this latest edition of
uh the January 6 committee hearings but
like yeah it was one thing I was like oh
work like this whole thing's gonna be up
about the text messages and the
documentary and I was like nope it's uh
way more than I thought
it's a lot it's a lot of stuff that they
went through and and there's a lot of
consequences that are going to come from
it because not only are we going to get
this subpoena but there's going to be
criminal referrals they made that very
clear as this report actually comes out
that's going to reveal more things that
they weren't didn't have enough time how
many hours did we figure that we were
doing coverage on this yesterday was it
45 plus full hours is that 40 yeah 45
Plus hours because I think on average
we've done five hours each but each one
has been a little over five hours so it
probably comes out to be like 46 hours
of of coverage that doesn't include the
the pre-production that we've done on
the show and and the post-production
that we've done on the show but the
actual just live coverage has been 45 46
hours right and that's that's a lot of
coverage on this on that one moment in
history right and it's because there was
so much involved and they haven't even
got to a tip of the iceberg yet of the
evidence and the thing that was striking
to me yesterday and I asked a lot of our
guests on the commentary panel and a lot
of people didn't think it was such a
serious deal but I see it as a huge huge
telling in history I actually believe
that that will be one of the things that
history will tell is while the January
6th select committee was subpoenaing
Donald Trump for his actions on January
6. The Oath Keepers who were charged
with seditious conspiracy who we found
out yesterday the Secret Service knew
they had the qrf the stash of weapons
across the Potomac they were on trial at
the very same time for some of the same
exact evidence that was being presented
not just in the halls of Congress for
January 6. the select committee but a
criminal federal court where these
people are going to receive stiff prison
sentence if they're found guilty by the
jury it is Stark it is it is a moment in
history and I believe that to not just
give that contrast of two sides of the
street there in Washington or one side
is a criminal trial the other side is a
political trial essentially
um and rightfully so against Donald
Trump and his allies like ryderstone
Mike Flynn Steve Bannon the John Eastman
Christina Bob Rudy Giuliani I'm telling
you there's gonna be a lot more news
after this this is not the end of the
January 6 select committee by any means
this is this is only the end of our
public hearings and folks it is up to
you to lean into your democracy to make
sure that in January that this select
committee still has the chance to keep
going if they need to keep investigating
these issues if new evidence appears it
is up to you you have to lean into your
democracy you have to participate we are
less than four weeks away from the most
important election of our democracy's
lifetime so get engaged lean into your
democracy because the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty and Liberty is what we fight for
that is what we fight for in this
country and that is what the January 6
elect committee is trying to bring to
the Forefront
should go to store.dmichaels.com if you
like the design here that's our that's
our that's our show's motto there's the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people's not it's not Liberty and really
what Donald Trump and his allies and the
band of insurrectionists I call them the
chart Army and all the people all the
people that were the generals of the
Sharden Army the bannons the flynns the
Roger Stones The Oath Keepers the proud
boys
they were trying to oppress your right
to vote is what they were trying to do
and the January 6th select committee
yesterday did that so well laying that
out I really felt like that yesterday
because we actually we had the biggest
ratings that we ever had and I feel like
yesterday was probably the most watched
hearing out of all of them even the
surprise one with Cassie Hutcherson I
think it's going to be the most watched
yeah I mean if I you know just a quick
uh quick look at the videos
I believe
uh uh I have to go because we had record
record-breaking audience library on on
the show I mean on the coverage to the
closest so yesterday was for you know
for anyone curious yesterday we had 211
000 people that have seen the hearing
the five-hour hearing so far just on
YouTube Just on just on YouTube and I
think I think on Facebook it was close
to 70 000 is what it was so so almost
300 000. I mean we've done 187 we've
done 150. I mean I'm not going to look
at the times here um yeah we might have
done over 40 46 hours but of coverage 45
to 50 hours of coverage on the January
6th so like hearings just here at the
minus touch Network and here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and again it's not over
their investigation is not over this
report's going to be put out they're
still collecting evidence that was
another groundbreaking piece of news
that uh representative Aguilar made
yesterday that hey we're still gonna
have the Secret Service come in and tell
us why they lied to us
um not in so many words but that's
basically the the aim of that of the
questioning so make sure do not forget
to subscribe here at the Tony Michaels
podcast we will stay on top of this
story as we do all of them make sure to
also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod vote for bonehead of the
week there follow me at the Tony
Michaels and Gabe Sanchez at I am Gabe
Sanchez
from the deep State phone booth also
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify Google and don't forget if you
are on Facebook on the Midas touch
Facebook page go follow us at the Tony
Michaels over there we brought guests
over there and there's a lot of cool
memes that we put up there funny stuff
that we find funny sometimes we make
them sometimes we just like this is good
this is great we're gonna share it with
our audience so go follow us if you're
on the books of face follow us on the
books face and the instagrammies I put
them up there too so if you're in more
on the Instagram folks have a safe great
weekend make sure to lean in as you go
through the weekend to your democracy
engage with your community your family
your friends your colleagues
anyone you run into at this the
barbecues that you're because I know the
weather's getting the weather's getting
barbecue whether it really is getting
cooler outside you're putting sweater
the football's happening over the
weekend so you're the grills
drinking some beers watching some
football
everyone have a safe weekend we'll see
on Monday same guy in the same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon